good afternoon and welcome to the Kirby
Center our guest today is the executive
editor for the national review as well
as a contributing editor to the Atlantic
and national affairs he's the son of
Bangladeshi immigrants born and raised
in New York he has appeared on numerous
radio and television programs including
NPR HBO BBC's Newsnight and Fox News's
Tucker Carlson tonight our guest is a
co-author of grand new party and the
sole author of his new book melting pot
or civil war please join me in welcoming
ryan ryan salam
thanks very much to Matt and Joe for
that very warm introduction and thanks
to all of you in the Hillsdale community
for welcoming me it's a true honor I've
had the pleasure of speaking at the
Kirby Center once before and it was a
great pleasure and I'm sure this will be
exactly the same so I am doing something
very unusual normally when I give talks
I tried to wing it I fly by the seat of
my pants so as to keep a sense of thrill
and excitement where you think that you
know maybe I will fall off my high wire
at any given moment but this time I
thought you know what why not actually
write something out so please forgive me
I might with my voice slowly put you to
sleep
do your best pinch your cheeks you know
just do whatever it is you need to do to
stay awake and and and come on this wild
journey with me we all know Donald Trump
wants a border wall which he sees as the
first line of defense against future
waves of unauthorized migration from
south of the Rio Grande we also know
that Democrats in Congress don't want a
border wall which they see as a hateful
symbol of exclusion and bigotry there's
much to be said about the politics of
the border wall and whether or not it
would make a meaningful cost-effective
contribution to controlling migration
flows before we get there though I want
to discuss a less concrete subject which
I would argue lies beneath all of the
shouting over the wall what does it mean
to be an American it's a question where
there is as I'm sure you've noticed
lively disagreement and it's this
disagreement that has made the politics
of immigration so unbelievably
contentious I see questions about
Americanist as questions about the
content of our nationalism a lot of the
time people use the term nationalism to
denote an ideology say a belief in the
superiority of one nation over all
others or a commitment to ethnic
chauvinism and militarism the
sociologist Bart Banach housekey uses a
different definition which I found
helpful Tabata Kowski nationalism simply
refers to the complex of ideas
sentiments and representations
by which Americans understand the United
States and their relationship to it
different conceptions of what it means
to be an American amount in this sense
two different nationalisms tonight I'll
introduce two different clashing
American nationalisms with an eye
towards thinking through their
implications for America's immigration
policy for most of American history the
United States has been closely
identified with its english-speaking
European origin majority this majority
has evolved and expanded over time and
there is much more to say about that for
now suffice it to say that most of those
who belong to this majority have felt
they could celebrate the US and its
achievements without hesitation you
could say that members of this majority
feel a sense of ownership they see
America as their country the same
couldn't always be said for all
Americans as there have always been
those who've felt something other than
fully American as something apart from
even excluded from the mainstream
majority consider African Americans
who've experienced discrimination or
who've heard stories of ancestors who
suffered grave and Justices there's
often a sense that their unique
historical experiences separate them
from some of their countrymen this isn't
always true to be sure but notions of
racial loyalty can at times be in
tension with an uncomplicated sense of
national loyalty think back to Muhammad
Ali a proud native of Louisville
Kentucky who died as a beloved
all-american figure yet who lived a life
stoked in controversy for one he refused
to fight in the Vietnam War on the
grounds that it was according to him at
the time a white man's war one of the
reasons Barack Obama's successful 2008
presidential campaign proved so
inspiring to many blacks is that it
seemed to promise a kind of
reconciliation though Obama couldn't
right every wrong he could bring
african-americans in ways large and
small into the heart of the American
story American nationalism could belong
to blacks and to other non-white
Americans but then
nationalism advanced by obama was of a
distinctive kind back in 2016 the
political analyst Jamelle Bouie writing
and Slade
perfectly distilled the Obama brand of
nationalism describing it as an
expression of pluralistic nationalism
and deep civic pride a progressive
patriotism that acknowledges the
nation's failures but strives to
overcome them of course not all love of
country takes this particular form it is
true that for many on the Left the only
decent form of nationalism is a
nationalism that amounts to a
celebration of the ongoing American
struggle to overcome injustice and to
implement various social reforms but for
many other Americans nationalism is
something more akin to the love of one's
family it is a celebration of our shared
cultural inheritance and a belief that
we owe more to our fellow countrymen
than we do to the rest of humanity in
his book strangers in our midst David
Miller a political theorist at Oxford
argued that national identity can foster
a sense of solidarity that goes well
beyond the standard civic duties of
paying your taxes staying out of trouble
and minding your own business people
feel emotionally attached to one another
because they share this identity rights
Miller their association becomes deeper
because the political community
conceives of itself as extended in time
indeed often as reaching back into
antiquity this also means that the
obligations it creates stretch backward
and forward they can be inherited from
the past and owed to future generations
but what happens in a diverse nation
like ours where a history of enslavement
and segregation separates blacks from
whites and what happens when the
cultural character of the nation-state
changes due to mass immigration what
happens is that we get clashing
conceptions of the nation which are
constantly competing with each other
Eric Hoffman a sociologist at Birkbeck
College and the author of an important
new book called white shift argues that
there is no such thing as a single
Universal 'i embraced national identity
in any society
rather different individuals see the
symbolic resources that serve as the
foundations for national identity
language history religious beliefs
shared ancestry and so on through
different ideological lenses over time
socially liberal individuals have sought
to redefine national identity as civic
and multicultural which is to say as
less tied to a particular ethnic
cultural community or to shared ancestry
and more tied to certain political
values such as adherence to liberal
democratic norms or a fondness for
cultural diversity
armed with this understanding of
national identity a person might
champion more open immigration policies
on the grounds that openness is what we
are all about and that the rejection of
openness is itself an American one is
reminded of the classic Barack Obama
line that's not who we are as a country
grows more open and inclusive however
there is often a reaction according to
Kaufman the increase in diversity caused
by high immigration levels can have the
effect of making ethnic distinctions
more salient in an age when immigrant
inflows are low or when they are dwarfed
by high native birth rates immigrants
are more like seasoning in the stew than
they are main ingredients the native
cultural majority can feel relaxed about
the presence of a few newcomers or even
in different when inflows are high or
when native birth rates are low or both
it's an entirely different story
in that case the rapid rise of immigrant
origin ethnic communities can really
make you stop and think about difference
and more specifically about what
differentiates your community from the
new communities that are growing in your
midst it can lead conservative
nationalists to fear that the America of
the future won't honor the American past
while elites tend to conceive of their
identity in Civic terms most people
conceived of their identity in ethnic
terms by ethnic I don't mean to invoke
scary blood and soil nationalism I just
mean that most people think
in terms of their inherited cultural
traditions and to use a formulation
laura ingraham invoked at the Republican
National Convention in 2016 they think
about where their dead are buried if
you're living in the same country as
your parents and your grandparents the
notion that you're really an immigrant
because your ancestors weren't here
before Columbus might seem pretty absurd
this is why scholars of immigrant
assimilation consider the third
generation meaningfully different from
the first and the second by the time
three generations have passed ties to
ancestral homelands are more symbolic
than real for the grandchildren of
immigrants it's really America that is
your ancestral homeland even if you
enjoy nothing more than partying hard on
st. Patrick's Day this becomes even
clearer when newcomers from different
cultures arrive and they offer a vivid
reminder that a third generation Irish
Italian mexican-american and a third
generation Japanese German Dutch
American have much more in common with
each other than either does with a
recent arrival from Bangladesh my
parents native country and what about
those recent immigrants as new
immigrants arrive they are typically
inclined to embrace less culturally
specific conceptions of American
national identity as doing so will mean
they won't be expected to surrender the
cultural traditions they've brought with
them from their homelands in this sense
at least they are closely aligned with
progressive nationalists if culturally
distinctive immigrants arrived in
sufficiently large numbers however they
can to reiterate prompt natives who
embrace an ethnic cultural conception of
nationhood to take their national
identity more seriously rather than less
some will seek to defend their cultural
community by calling for limits on
immigration and by emphasizing the
importance of a common national language
and culture too many Americans these
responses to mass immigration aren't
just defensible they are necessary I'm
sympathetic to these views myself
nevertheless members of minority ethnic
groups often find them alienating
there's an irony here of course
immigrants who want to hold on to their
cultural traditions actually have a lot
in common with majority group members
who want to do the same and who worry
about the declining relative influence
of their ethnic cultural community or
even about its eventual extinction but
the shared desire for cultural
continuity plays out differently for
recent immigrants and for traditionalist
natives recent immigrants find
themselves in a tacit alliance with
people who hold secular or cosmopolitan
values rather than with their fellow
traditionalists one wonders if we'll
ever see a scrambling of these alliances
will one conception of national identity
eventually vanquished the other not a
chance
both have staying power conservative
nationalists might find progressive
nationalism irritating and destructive
but it's not going anywhere
progressive nationalists might consider
a conservative nationalism retrograde if
not immoral but they need to face the
fact that it is a permanent feature of
the landscape and while it might wane in
some periods it will wax in others why
does the persistence of these two
conceptions of nationalism matter on all
sorts of issues this distinction between
progressive nationalism and conservative
nationalism isn't terribly germane there
are progressive nationalists and
conservative nationalists who favor
medicare-for-all and who oppose it or
who want to hike taxes on the rich or
who want to unleash entrepreneurial
energy as by slashing red tape on
immigration though this distinction is
absolutely central and it makes a
compromise exceptionally difficult to
hammer out a progressive nationalism
that identifies all that is great in
America with political movements like
those the champion women's equality gay
rights and criminal justice reform
welcomes cultural change because
progressive nationalism is not really
rooted in the idea of a shared cultural
inheritance the same can't be said of a
conservative nationalism that maintains
that the American nation is rooted in a
particular language and culture these
different visions of American national
identity have been around for ages but
high levels of immigration
and the distinctions between them to
those on the left
rising diversity necessitates a further
move away from a more culturally
specific understanding of what it means
to be an American they see it as
dangerously exclusive and divisive if we
are all united by the struggle to
overcome our nation's failures rather
than by a common culture it is natural
to see unauthorized immigrants as part
of a story that stretches back to the
civil rights movement if not to
abolitionism these days it's not
uncommon to hear efforts to deport
unauthorized immigrants to efforts to
enforce the Fugitive Slave Act in the
years prior to the Civil War this is
what I call sanctuary progressivism or
the notion that unauthorized immigrants
should be defined not as lawbreakers but
as a vulnerable and oppressed minority
in need of protection if we are united
by our shared cultural inheritance
however it is natural to expect that
immigrants embrace the culture that
defines the native majority and that
decisions about immigration policy
should be made in the interests of the
most vulnerable members of our cultural
community not in the interests of
outsiders who choose to violate our laws
in short there is just no way to get an
immigration solution that fully realizes
the moral historical vision of the
conservative nationalists or the
progressive nationalists even so I
believe there's a compromise to be had
like all compromises it will be less
than ideal and it will leave just about
everyone at least slightly disappointed
I hope to elaborate on the exact
contours of the compromise I have in
mind during the question and answer
session briefly I want to underscore
that the key to a compromise is to
bridge this yawning normative divide to
devise a settlement that leaves
conservative nationalists and
progressive nationalists feeling as
though they've been listened to and
respected and to get there we will have
to do at least three things first we
have to accept that there is going to be
some kind of amnesty for some number of
unauthorized immigrants why is that
two-thirds of the unauthorized immigrant
population has been in the country
for over ten years you have a huge swath
of unauthorized immigrant adults who
have US citizen children living in the
United States and one thing we've
learned in the trump era is that talk of
large-scale deportation of folks who've
been in the country for ten years or
more actually reduces support for
sensible and sane controlled immigration
this is a huge political challenge for
conservative nationalists to bring in
any number of progressive nationalists
you have to have some settlement of the
question of unauthorized immigrants who
are long term residents second we ought
to modernize the u.s. immigration system
with an eye towards better serving the
interests of Americans given change in
public opinion it is going to be very
difficult to make a case for steep
reductions in future immigration levels
but an increased emphasis on skills and
language ability is broadly popular and
it particularly speaks to the concerns
of conservative nationalists third we
need an ambitious program of immigrant
integration one that would ensure
immigrants have the resources they need
to learn English and to be full
participants in the civic and economic
life of the nation short of such an
effort there is I fear a real danger
that some of today's immigrants will
give rise to a new underclass that sees
itself as permanently excluded from the
American mainstream this is a project
that could and should appeal the
conservative and progressive
nationalists alike
thank you very much I understand that
people have very passionate and strong
views about these issues I have pretty
strong views about them myself but it's
really important that we just reckon
with the fact that while I myself might
be a conservative nationalist I take
that idea of a shared cultural
inheritance very seriously the difficult
truth is that my views are not shared by
the entire American population these are
views it will be very very difficult to
legislate into existence without
acknowledging that bitter and determined
opposition on the other side and that's
why somehow reframing this conversation
as a way of achieving some kind of Civic
peace is really really important I know
I've talked about a lot of
different issues and I welcome any and
all of your questions thank you very
much thank you for speaking sir
I know it's a difficult topic and you
and I probably agree beyond the
buzzwords on any number of things but
how can we have a legislated amnesty
given the failure of the amnesty in the
1980s to solve our problems and
especially when between the Ninth
Circuit and the DC Circuit Court we have
any number of judges who would be
willing to open up a partial amnesty to
all kinds of other illegal immigrants
saying that would be unfair and not
equal opportunity to block them this is
a really important question and first
I'm going to talk about the 1986 burka
amnesty if you look at the immigration
reform and Control Act the basic idea
was very similar to the idea that you
hear me talking about right now and
that's one reason why people are so
reluctant to pursue a similar kind of
change the idea was we are going to
introduce stringent interior enforcement
measures and that is going to be the
other half and then we're gonna
regularize this population that by the
way wound up being much larger than they
originally anticipated for some of the
reasons you described there was rampant
fraud and much else so here's the really
key important thing that happened back
then there was a very powerful
constituency on the political right that
opposed workplace enforcement workplace
enforcement was really central to the
idea of Orca and workplace enforcement
here's the tricky thing that ran against
the interests of many low-wage employers
that's why workplace enforcement was
from the very beginning weakened
weakened to the point where it was
really just a purely pro forma kind of
idea you know you present a variety of
different documents many of them might
be fraudulent and then we'll just call
it a day right there wasn't really
stringent enforcement and also there was
this other tactic where lots of firms
would not
workers directly but rather would work
through contractors who would take on
that legal liability so that was another
way to kind of shield low-wage employers
a couple of things have happened since
then that have had a pretty big effect
one is you have a little something
called Eve Arif I and II verify is not
perfect it is not flawless but is a
pretty darn effective workplace
enforcement measure it is so effective
in fact that you have a lot of folks in
that kind of anti borders Lobby who are
vigorously resisting efforts to make Eve
Arif I mandatory and you have some
state-level officials by the way who
have been making it mandatory and we see
that in fact mandatory e-verify is quite
effective at deterring
the employment of unauthorized folks and
given that many of them are you know the
vast majority of them are seeking
employment this makes a very very big
difference so that is one critical
difference between now and then another
big difference is that the American
economy has changed since the 1980s I
know that's gonna be a big shock to a
lot of folks in the room okay so one of
the big ways that's changed is also had
a knock-on effect on the politics of
immigration if you're looking at the
1980s this was a time when we still had
a quite large low-wage low-skill
manufacturing employment base since then
that has not that has deteriorated for
all sorts of reasons but the really big
reason is offshoring one way to think
about immigration is that immigration is
a tool that allows us firms and
consumers and employers to gain access
to the hard work of talented people from
elsewhere in the world but guess what
offshoring means trade means that you
can now partner with workers in other
countries without actually importing
foreign labor if you're looking at the
iPhone the iPhone is not built by huge
numbers of low-skilled low-wage workers
in California and Michigan for better
for worse you have us designers who are
working with Chinese workers to produce
this amazing product so I'm not saying
that's a good thing or a bad thing I'm
simply saying that's a reality right and
so what's happened is that those
manufacturing employers who used to be a
really important constituency for low
wage immigration they were
really important constituency for
resisting workplace enforcement they're
just not there anymore they might care
about high-skill high-wage employment
but they're not really there for kind of
huge inflows of low-skill employment and
one knock-on consequence of that is that
the pro-immigration side has become a
lot less pragmatic a lot less oriented
around the interests of employers and a
lot more ideological a lot more based in
basically a cosmopolitan ideology which
holds that it is presumptively
illegitimate to have any kind of
immigration control at all so those are
some really really big changes since
1986 and I believe that if you look at
the present we have the tools to make
immigration enforcement far more
effective than we did back then that's
one thing another thing is that when
you're looking at that unauthorized
immigrant population in the 1980's it
was quite different for one it was very
heavily male which is why you had this
big chain migration reaction after
people were given legal status if you're
looking at the current population again
two-thirds of that population has been
in the country for over ten years and a
huge amount of it has family ties a huge
part of that current population comes
from Mexico that was also true in the 86
wave but Mexico is actually aging more
rapidly than the United States if you're
looking at future flows of unauthorized
migration they are coming from other
places where we have a greater ability
to control the flow for example through
visas that make it very hard
you can't take a boat from Bangladesh or
Senegal to Florida you just can't do it
the way that you can cross the border
right the way that you can cross the Rio
Grande so these are all things that make
the picture a bit different and that I
think would make such a bargain more
effective but I'd be happy to talk about
this with you further you spent a lot of
time talking about how protecting your
form of nationalism that you
particularly hear to my question is mmm
broadly about what you think nationalism
is in the context that if you look
throughout the world if you ask you for
what nationalism is for example and
it's very clear what nationalism is
because it was born in you know after
the modern era when it was basically a
reaction of ethnic autonomy towards a
multicultural or trans cultural elite
that was broadly hereditary and in the
Americas it's it's different nationalism
in the modern era in America's is
basically people from the spoke the same
language as the people they were trying
to break off from like in in South
America or in North America when we were
speaking people were breaking off from
Britain so what what exactly to you what
do you think nationalism is what is the
core you've explained a lot about how
you're wanting to protect it the what
exactly is the core of what you think
American nationalism is if it's not an
ethnic if it doesn't have an ethnic
basis to it thank you very much for that
question you give me an opportunity to
clarify the point of my my talk is that
when I'm talking about nationalism I'm
just talking about different people's
conceptions of the nation how they
relate to it how they understand
themselves in that context so for
example my form of nationalism is not
universal which is why I wouldn't say
that this is what nationalism is what
nationalism is to me is this idea of a
cultural community that has some kind of
continued existence it's this notion
that you know I was born in 1979 but I
am deeply connected to folks who are you
know kind of of earlier eras when I'm
thinking about you know English settlers
from the 17th century for example I feel
like they are part they are in line with
my cultural inheritance they are part of
me there are other people for whom
that's not their understanding of
American life what it means to them of
their place in American life you know
some of them might see the United States
as a flag of convenience you know what
happens at the United States is an
affluent safe prosperous country and I
happen to live here but maybe next week
I could live in Singapore or I can live
in London or elsewhere and they might
say gosh my America is an America that's
built around the market and freedom and
these various other ideals and
America is really the way I want the
world to be it just happens that we got
here first that's a more ideological
conception of what it means to be an
American and that to me is another kind
of nationalism but you're right other
people talk about nationalism in totally
different ways right some people say
that it's some kind of awful extremism
or something like that or you know it's
simply another word for patriotism so in
this talk I was using in a very specific
sense to refer to how people make sense
of their place in the nation and how
they think of the national community and
my point is just that you know because
you have those different conceptions it
really complicates some of these
sensitive issues like immigration that
really have bearing on the future
composition of the nation or how our
ideas of a nation might change in the
future well when you think about
assimilation there are lots of different
ways to define it one way to define it
is simply that assimilation involves
immigrants becoming more like natives
more like the average among natives
right here's the funny thing though the
average among natives is a moving target
right so let's say a hundred years from
now the United States experienced a huge
amount of migration from Turkish
Buddhists okay and the average American
in the Year 2150 is a Turkish speaking
Buddhist who loves doner kebab and you
know kind of who just kind of really
really loves the Buddha then
assimilation in that narrow technical
sense means that I'm assimilating to
whatever happens to be the norm in this
future America there's another way of
thinking about assimilation which is
that you know it's to a specific
conception of American life right
assimilation is a segmented phenomenon
it's a phenomenon that you know means
different things for members of
different groups so for example let's
say you're a Nigerian American and you
come to the United States you could
assimilate into the African American
community that's pretty darn different
from your Nigerian traditions right
but that could be one way you enter the
country or you could assimilate into you
know kind of the Latino community
through intermarriage and by kind of
embracing some different conception you
know there is an American mainstream
there is an American cultural majority
but fundamentally the way one
assimilates in Texas is gonna be
different from one house immolates in
New York that doesn't mean that we don't
want to encourage the idea of some kind
of common culture but it's simply a
reality that you know you are becoming
more like a certain class of natives but
natives are pretty darn diverse right so
that's gonna look pretty different
depending on circumstances now someone
like me thinks the idea of certain
shared cultural ideals shared cultural
practices is really important for
binding a country together but in a
nation of 330 million people
I've got to tell you assimilation really
is just gonna look different depending
all sorts of other circumstances and one
of the big things that I focus on in
this book is actually the way that class
plays into this so let's say you're
someone who comes into the country
already you speak English
already you have a lot of education
already you find yourself surrounded by
lots of other native-born Americans you
think of them as your neighbors and your
friends you think of them as fully part
of your life you might even marry one
right that's a very different way of
becoming an American then if you are
someone who is really darn poor you're
someone who moves to an ethnic Enclave
surrounded by other people who look like
you who sound like you with similar
skills and cultural traditions those
people both of them might assimilate in
the sense of becoming more like people
who are natives but in really really
different ways right they're
assimilating into different class groups
so I think that that's an important
thing to keep in mind
hi my name is John Saddam and I'm from
Reason Foundation so you talked a lot it
talked a little bit about how we need to
grant amnesty to illegal immigrants who
have been in the country for ten years
but there's also a large population of
people who have been in the country
illegally and for a lot of reasons they
might not be even up for it doesn't
really mean they're gonna have a be
granted citizenship or even a green card
status so how is that American that we
grant a path to citizenship to all these
people who have been here illegally
while there is tons of people who have
been here legally did everything
correctly have worked hard in taxes that
everything and we don't even talk about
that this is an incredibly helpful
question it's a helpful question because
it illustrates these different
conceptions of nationalism right so what
our questioner has done is introduced an
ideological conception of the nation it
would be unamerican for us to embrace
her specific policy proposal this is
something that Barack Obama of course
did all the time and people do you know
you say that hey if you favor a 70
percent top marginal tax rate that is
unamerican because America is a country
that rewards hard work and enterprise
right I mean this is an argument that it
is very classically American you could
say now I guess my view is that I have
very very specific views about exactly
what our legal immigration system ought
to look like you know one pretty tricky
issue we have is that if you look at for
example employment-based green cards in
the United States they're offered in an
incredibly arbitrary opaque basis so if
you're someone who's in the country with
an h-1b visa that's a visa for
high-skilled workers your path to
getting a green card can be incredibly
winding complicated and crazy and
inconsistent in a way that can be really
really frustrating I personally think
that we ought to have a more transparent
and predictable path that basically says
to people hey look these are the
ingredients of labor market success we
want you to speak the language we want
you to be really incorporated into
American culture but we're not making
this a totally arbitrary crazy system
we're making it predictable coherent
transparent I do write about this a fair
bit in the book but I personally think
that you know when it comes to crafting
and immigration
compromise emphasis on compromise you
have to do things that are purely based
in my particular principles or ideals
right if I could do that I would be
called a dictator not a commentator on
public affairs so I guess when I'm
thinking about this bargain I'm
certainly not saying I'm actually pretty
explicitly not saying that it's going to
satisfy everyone it's going to be
incredibly frustrating to many people
but what I hope to do is create some
kind of rough-and-ready workable
compromise that we can all live with
when you think about America's system of
constitutional government you know it's
really incredible it's very frustrating
the progressives why because it requires
broad overlapping majorities you both
have the house then you've also got the
Senate you've got a present you've got
all of these different branches that
create all of these different veto
points now if you're a progressive who
wants to impose your vision of what a
perfect modern social democratic America
is going to look like you find these
veto points extremely frustrating right
hey right now I've got my 51% majority
why can't I RAM everything I want
through because the founders had this
little thought we want a broad
overlapping majority for legislation
particularly on really central questions
like immigration so I promise you there
are literally dozens of people in this
room who could come up with a beautiful
perfect wonderful immigration scheme but
the nature of our system is that it's
not about one faction imposing its will
on everybody it's about everyone taking
their lumps and actually coming up with
something that is going to create that
broad overlapping majority
hi about legal migration we finally
legitimate the term a migration and
sorry can you chain migration and and
rather than talking t erratically about
nationalism and all that stuff the
fundamental thing is what is a good
policy and how to legitimate it in a
political discussion with the left
everybody knows that every angry
Democrat always moves to Canada for some
reason not to Guatemala I don't
understand why they want a certain
border but that's what they threatened
to do so
Canada has a very important merit-based
immigration system but we say
merit-based but I also the second
component which is very important is an
on chain migration so to immigrate to
Canada you have to collect points in a
very clear system based on education
language all that stuff so they get the
best and the brightest but then that's
all what explain to the American public
you can go there only you your wife and
your kids no mother's no father's no
brothers no sisters no cousins no and I
think I'm still puzzled why the American
right or whatever you want to call the
group who actually want this country to
attract the best labor force that we can
attract does not embrace this kind of
argument to say let's be like Canada
without all these theories you know they
just to me that's a very strong argument
so first of all I advocate a move to a
more Skills based immigration system but
there's a slight problem with with your
characterization of the Canadian system
so if you look at the Canadian system
it's true that they do have a
points-based system for many migrants
but they actually also accept far more
family migrants than the United States
does if the United States accepted as
many migrants as Canada does for
permanent visas we would be accepting
about 3 million every year rather than 1
million I personally believe that Canada
admits to many but that's a whole
separate conversation I'm happy to have
and if you look at the Canadian system
that's actually not quite right so what
they do is they actually give intending
immigrants
points for adaptability tied to having a
relative in the country I believe that
that is a pretty sensible approach
because it says that okay you have a
sibling let's say and they do count
siblings by the way you have that and
that can be factored in among many other
considerations so you know when I think
about what would be a sensible legal
immigration system that could command
broad majority support you know I guess
my starting point is that you know maybe
I would want to reduce levels but there
is not nearly enough public support for
that in fact you know only about 30% of
the public wants to reduce legal
immigration levels so what I would say
is we can keep levels roughly steady but
what we'll do is this we will modernize
the existing employment based categories
to make them more like a point system
that is predictable and sensible and
then we will take the family preference
categories for siblings and
what-have-you and then we will say no
this is also going to be a points-based
system but for these visas you can get a
small number of points for having a
relative I think that that seems like a
sensible moderate compromise but the
truth is that the Canadian system is
certainly not perfect in every respect
we could certainly learn from it but I
wouldn't mimic it in every detail
there's more to say about that but I'd
be happy to discuss that with you
further
thank you for coming in speaking again
so regarding the ethics of immigration
when you're considering two candidates
and is it proper to give merit to a more
highly productive candidate does that
insinuate any kind of ethical issues
from your perspective or one that you
could empathize with and does that
create a wholly egalitarian method of
bringing in immigrants and why are why
not
so I basically I don't think of this
through the lens of moral philosophy I
really do try to think about this
through the lens of practical politics
and from my perspective if you look at
the history of American immigration
policy we've always maintained a
distinction between migrants who settle
in the country on a humanitarian basis
refugees and asylum seekers and other
migrants when it comes to those other
migrants for over a hundred years we've
had a notion in American law called
public charged status and this idea of
the public charge this actually goes way
further back in American history if you
look at the debates over immigration in
the nineteenth century we had really big
conversations about keeping poppers out
of the country people who were so
desperately poor that they would not be
able to support themselves but rather
would depend on the charity of others
now that might not sound very friendly
or humane but that has always been a
bedrock principle of American
immigration law now one thing that's
happened in recent years is that many
immigration advocates have in various
ways blurred the distinction between
humanitarian migration and non
humanitarian migration and I think that
this is a pretty big mistake because it
really is true that you know for a
country like ours with a long history of
welcoming the persecuted there is some
place for welcoming political refugees
folks who are fleeing religious
persecution in some reasonable numbers
where we can actually accommodate this
and we can incorporate people into our
communities but overall immigration was
seen as a means of building the country
and when you want
build the country you're not thinking so
much in humanitarian terms as thinking
about who are people who are not just be
self-sufficient but who will be people
who will be able to support their
families and help build flourishing
communities now I happen not to find
that idea offensive I think that idea is
pretty sensible the idea that yes
there's a place a limited bounded place
for humanitarian considerations but
overall I think it's pretty legitimate
to say that our immigration system
should serve the national interest and
particularly the interests of our
existing citizens you know again not
everyone's gonna agree on that but I've
got to tell you of the vast majority of
Americans regardless of where they come
down on the number of folks we ought to
welcome into the country do accept that
basic premise that we have the right to
decide what makes the most sense for us
and what makes the most sense for us I
would argue changes from time to time in
the year in 1910 it was very different
from what it was in the year 2000 and
what it's going to be in the year 2030
that's why I think that it's perfectly
legitimate and sensible to say that we
are going to shift those criteria over
time
now you mentioned this idea of economic
potential and whether it's legitimate to
take that into account
when it comes to refugees I think that
you know that really shouldn't be the
chief consideration right there are a
variety of other factors including
strategic considerations that might come
in to that when it comes to migrants who
are expected to support themselves
because again the public charge doctrine
is not something I made up today it's
something that's been a principle of
American law for over a century I think
it's reasonable to take into account
that person's economic potential so you
know there's a lot more to say on this
subject but that's basically how I see
it and I'm happy to talk to you about it
further
thank you for being here I'm curious in
your opening statement I think a second
sentence you mentioned about the
Democrats motivation was their offense I
guess to the immorality of the wall yet
of course they have walls and gates all
around them so is the consideration that
perhaps it's to expand their voter base
part of their motivation and secondly I
had a question regarding the the big
business current day emphasis or
preference for the cheap labor pool you
could address that please sure so if
you're looking at that first point I
guess I find it helpful to try to
inhabit people's perspectives I might
have a pretty cynical interpretation of
what it is that Democrats want to do but
I think it's useful to try to amaya
their shoes you know it's certainly
possible that there are a lot of
Democrats out there who just really have
a diabolical plan to take over the
country and that's why they're they kind
of favor this or that policy I'm sure
that's true of some people but I do
think that there are a lot of people for
whom they believe they might be wrong
but they believe their views on
immigration are rooted in some sense of
what is just what is good and what is
true and your that could also relate to
electoral politics they might think that
you know we will expand this majority to
do things that we think are right that
are in keeping with our vision of what
America ought to be so even though I
disagree with them pretty strongly I do
think that it's helpful for me to
discipline my thinking by thinking about
you know what's the best case for their
perspective rather than the worst case
now when it comes to employers this is a
really this is a subject that I think is
very that's not understood as well as it
could be understood so I think that when
you think about the labor force changing
the labor force
changes the way that employers do
business so for example if you have a
labor force that is highly educated and
highly productive you basically have to
structure your business models
differently than if you have a huge
number of workers who don't have a lot
of skills right so for example if you
have a country that has a very highly
educated population it's a lot more
likely that you'll use machines to do a
lot of back-breaking physical work then
that you'll use huge armies of people
you know if you have to pay high wages
that's another reason to economize on
labor right when you think about
American history one of the reasons that
this is the country that created
interchangeable parts you know that
innovated in all sorts of ways in all
sorts of labor saving ways it's partly
because on the frontier for example you
know we didn't always have a huge
abundance of labor it led to the use of
ingenuity and creativity so when it
comes to employers and their agenda I
would argue that different employers
have pretty different agendas if you're
an employer who thinks that hey my labor
force is mostly in China you know what I
do here is I have some research and
design and you know kind of so you're
not really worried as much about getting
access to cheap labor right maybe you're
thinking well I just want to be sure
that I can get the best engineers for
example and the best engineers they can
be pretty expensive but you're not as
concerned about that there are other
businesses however where their business
model would cease to exist without
low-cost labor so in that case they
might be really motivated to secure as
much low-cost labor as they can but I
don't think that business is monolithic
on this front I think that you actually
see really big divides among different
kind of businesses depending on the
business models they depend on but happy
to discuss that that a greater length
still I'd like to go back to the
question you raised about sponsorship
I'm agent enough to realize that my
father after World War two signed it
signed into the country any number of
uncles aunts cousins with the proviso
that they would not be unwell fair for
two years
and a number of them slept on the
living-room couch for about six months
until they could get their feet on the
ground when did that change this is a
wonderful question and it is it really
speaks to a kind of revolution in the
welfare state so if you're looking at
folks who secure green cards in the
United States right now unless you
entered the less you secured your status
as a refugee or as an acai Li in those
cases you're immediately eligible for a
wide swath of safety net benefits if you
aren't in one of those categories you
are subject to a temporary five-year ban
it's called on accessing a range of
different safety net benefits but that
ban has a lot of holes running through
it you know for one thing if you have
kids they're not subject to that band
right it's subject to the actual you
know kind of initiating person the adult
and then there's the fact that there are
all sorts of things that are not
technically safety net benefits that
really function as safety net benefits
for example the Earned Income Tax Credit
the Earned Income Tax Credit is a
provision of the tax code which says
that if your wages fall below a certain
level you will get a refund check
quote-unquote from Uncle Sam that is
designed to defray payroll taxes or more
than that but you know that is something
that really makes a big difference for a
lot of folks and it's you could argue a
kind of welfare right so in that case
you know you are immediately eligible
for that and it's kind of a funny thing
because people who say that we have a
desperate need for lots of low-skilled
low-wage labor what they don't
acknowledge is that well if we had such
a desperate need for it clearly the
wages would be somewhat higher right we
wouldn't need the Earned Income Tax
Credit and other a fundable tax credits
to really top-up people's incomes so I
think that you know that is a really
tricky thing you know there are some
people who say that oh these immigrants
they're lazy they don't know I mean
they're immigrants who do work the
problem is that in many cases their
skills are such that they can't really
command high enough incomes to support
themselves and their families now the
Trump administration
proposed revising the public charged
status basically revising how we think
of what makes you a public charge or not
right now the rules we have on the books
our rules that were established by Bill
Clinton in 1999 and under those rules
you're really only considered a public
charge if you get all of your income
from cash welfare or if you're literally
being institutionalized but if you
collect you know if you rely on Medicaid
if you you know collect snap if you
collect the EITC it's all of these other
things you wouldn't count as a public
charge President Trump has said let's
try to fix that let's try to have a more
modern and someone argue sensible
conception of what it means to be a
public charge which says that we have
this expectation that you are going to
support yourself now to the point about
families here's a hilarious story so
under federal law since 1996 if you are
sponsoring a relative you really are
responsible and if that relative does
collect a safety net benefit the public
sector has the right to engage in
sponsor recovery to collect money from
the person who sponsored that immigrant
guess what sponsor recovery has never
ever happened Mike Bloomberg the former
mayor of New York tried to do it he
asked for a voluntary contribution from
folks who sponsored immigrants and you
know he collected in a city of eight and
a half million people he collected about
five hundred thousand bucks when bill de
blasio came back into office he said
this is an outrage and he returned the
money so basically this thing that is
literally on the books is never enforced
and whenever anyone talks about
enforcing this very basic common-sense
provision they're run out of town on a
rail it's a the idea is that this is
some kind of terrible awful thing now
there was one proposal Republicans in
the house proposed in the good luck bill
what they said is you know right now if
you were the parent of a US citizen you
can enter the country without limit it's
an unlimited number of folks who can
come now you know again you know if
you're the parent of a US citizen you
might be an elderly person you might be
an elderly person who needs a nursing
home you might be someone who relies not
just on Medicare but also in Medicaid
and a variety of other benefits now you
know there are some kind of limits on
that here and there
but you know fundamentally we ought to
do in my opinion with the Canadians do
what the Canadians say is that you can
bring your adult parent that's great
you're a wonderful person
congratulations for being such a dutiful
child but it's going to be on a
temporary renewable five year visa and
you only keep the visa if you purchase
health insurance for that parent now to
me that seems like a pretty sensible
idea we're not saying you cannot bring
the relative what we're saying is that
you must be held responsible if you're
gonna be so wonderfully generous well be
wonderfully generous right and I do
think that bringing that principle back
into our immigration system that you
describe would make a world of
difference and by the way I just want to
stress there are some sponsors who take
their responsibilities seriously but
there are a whole heck of a lot of
others who aren't even educated about
what their responsibility is and what it
means law serves a tutelary function
when we do not enforce some of these
laws we send people a very bad message
that these laws are to be ignored
they're not to be taken seriously that
this supposed responsibility is really
just a piece of paper and that also has
lots of negative consequences for how we
think about assimilation thanks for
coming on late-night TV there's often a
lot of skits that are comedic of the man
on the street that doesn't understand
civics history or social studies
whatever you want to talk about it you
used the word assimilation so many times
tonight but you haven't mentioned
specifically how the people that are
here illegally that you want to keep
here can assimilate and understand the
trouble that those people behind you
went through to craft the Constitution
to understand the Constitution and to
abide by the Constitution what are your
specific ideas well sure sure sure there
are many different pieces to your
question one is this question
civic education for all Americans
whether they're foreign border
native-born I've got to tell you I think
that civic education for native-born
folks is not where it ought to be in my
humble opinion and I do think this is
something we need to invest in and take
seriously when it comes to unauthorized
migrants you know I've got to say I
think that this population is a
population that is aging very rapidly
you are talking about a population where
the share that is over the age of 50 is
growing enormous Lee and you know by the
time you're looking at you know 10 or 15
years from now you're gonna look at
folks who are not really the seedbed of
the next generation these are not people
who are going to be shaping our civic
life unfortunately or fortunately you
know kind of whatever your view on this
is these are folks who oftentimes have
spent you know most of their adult lives
in the United States they've done it in
very low wage work they've done it
really toiling in the shadows they've
done it without any kind of big idea of
taking part in our civic life if you
look at that older amnesty from 1986 we
talked about at the beginning of the Q&A
session one of the really striking
things is that of the roughly 3 million
folks who are legalized actually huge
numbers of them never became naturalized
citizens you actually had a wave of them
who became naturalized citizens in 96
why is that because in 96 you started
talking about well one hypothesis is
that you started talking about limiting
safety net benefits for folks who were
in citizens so then there was like an
immediate visceral reason to kind of get
involved in a political fray but there's
a huge number of people they just wanted
the legal status they weren't thinking
you know I want to vote in elections or
something like that they just you know
wanted to be assured that they're not
gonna get kicked out of the country
that's not necessarily a good thing but
when we're thinking about the practical
on-the-ground realities of that you know
that's one thing to keep in mind and
when you're thinking about folks who
were granted some kind of legal status
you know one way to do that is to say
that okay if you came into the country
as a minor then okay maybe you might
eventually become a citizen but if you
did not come into the country as a minor
you know there are a lot of folks who
might say well I don't think it's
entirely fair to say that that person
ought to jump ahead of many other people
who enter the country lawfully
to become a citizen right that doesn't
mean that civic education doesn't matter
but it does present a different set of
questions and challenges I'd be happy to
talk to you about that further but look
you know I agree with you a hundred
percent civic education matters a huge
amount it absolutely matters for
immigrants but I do believe that this is
a problem that's not a niche issue that
just applies to this one group of folks
it applies to all Americans it is the
duty of all of us to teach our children
about our constitutional ideals to make
sure that they continue to be defended
and cherished for future generations
thank you very much
[Applause]